[Music]
hello there welcome to the session on
moving from raw data to ml faster with
bigquery and vertex AI
my name is Paul long Lin and with me
today is Erwin huizenga and we're both
developer advocates for Google Cloud at
the intersection of data and AI I'll be
giving an overview and then Irwin will
show a demo of data to ml and Beyond at
the end of the session
so let's first talk about the problems
from data to ml
for many organizations today there's
still a barrier between data and machine
learning that slows down innovation
data can be big multi-formatted in
different places hard to discover and AI
ml systems are often thought of as a
separate and sort of siled from the data
warehouses and data Lakes of an
organization and and this sort of
results in slower speed and capacity to
innovate quickly with AI and ml so in
order to address this we need to have a
common understanding of how data flows
from raw data to machine learning and
downstream insights and activations and
you'll see here how data engineering
helps prepare the data sources for data
analytics which then enables model
development I.E or machine learning
models followed by deployment and
serving and then finally using the
results of the models to inform decision
making or to serve applications directly
and importantly you may also want to
automate and orchestrate these together
where possible as well so how does
Google Cloud help with all of this
with Google's data Cloud we cover all
users all processes roles applications
data types across the whole stack and
all of our data and AI services are part
of a unified platform and remove
historical workload barriers that tend
to pop up between different applications
so how do you begin on this journey to
innovating faster with ml to
personalizing your products and services
better with ml to to to do better
forecasting so you can prepare rather
than to respond using ml well to do that
we have a crawl walk run Journey we like
to share with you on how you can get up
and running as quickly as possible with
data to ml
so if your data is stored in bigquery in
cloud storage or even elsewhere you can
use vertex AI workbench as a notebook
first approach towards doing data
science with your data now this may seem
simple but this Foundation enables your
data analysts and data scientists to use
jupyter notebooks running on Google
Cloud to explore your data to access
your data to create insights and
visualizations rapidly
and this opens up the door for a common
environment for those comfortable with
SQL with with python R tensorflow Pi
torch Apache spark you name it to use
notebooks as a way to get some insights
from your data right away and I'll bring
here as well uh this quote from a
customer of Google Cloud Subaru
Corporation who says the following they
say I chose Google Cloud for many
platforms because at the time of
selection it had multiple managed
services such as vertex Ai and the
managed notebooks option and vertex AI
training that were useful for AI
development and and that's a that's a
great quote because it quickly segues
into this next section on training and
deploying your ml models so notebooks
with vertex a workbench becomes a a
seamless kind of path into the whole
spectrum of any data science and machine
learning work for your organization from
exploring your data in bigquery or
accessing your data in cloud storage
using big lake to pre-processing your
data whether that's in bigquery data
flow or spark with with dataproc the
training your model through automl
bigquery ml which is your machine
learning within your bigquery
environment or custom models which could
be you know tensorflow Pi torch cycle
learn extra boost your favorite package
which can then be all registered these
models into model registry on vertex Ai
and then from there you can do model
predictions and have built-in
explainable Ai and this could be done
with uh bigquery ml or using vertex AI
endpoints and then you serve those
predictions
um do some Downstream application
locations or to inform decision making
and depending on your needs
so as part of this overall flow we're
also happy to announce that model
registry is now in GA so you can
register any of your models in model
registry whether it was trained using
automl bigquery ml or custom models like
scikit-learn xgboost tensorflow Pi torch
and so on in model registry lets you
easily reuse models use labels and
aliases to keep track of your models and
also version your models as well so for
model register you can easily deploy
your models to vertex vertex AI
endpoints as well making it really easy
to push your models into production and
then do your predictions thereafter and
there's also a fantastic SDK in Python
to help you use your models in model
registry along the way
so that was uh crawling with your
notebook environment and walking with
your model training uh development and
deployment by taking a step further how
do you run with machine learning so this
is where you start thinking about
orchestration in automation akin to an
ml platform so you can add in relevant
mlops capabilities like Ci CD a feature
store to do your feature management and
sharing vertex AI pipelines to stitch
together various operations into single
pipeline flow
um and I also wanted to uh raise a quote
from a customer here uh Apna who say
that they're data scientists
traditionally spend the majority of
their time obtaining the data massaging
the data removing outliers performing
everything that comes under the category
of machine learning or mlops and vertex
a automated most of that burden making
everything simple for us so that's a
it's a great quote and thank you Abner
um so I just wanted to hone in on a
little a little bit around pipelines
here when it comes to orchestration what
does that sort of thing look like when
it comes to orchestration here with
pipelines so if if you imagine instead
of running individual training or
deployment steps manually or ad hoc you
can instead stitch them together using
components of a Vertex AI pipeline that
you can then trigger schedule or execute
as a single uh flow and we're also happy
to announce that these components now
support bigquery ml as well so you can
use vertex AI pipelines to easily stitch
together various bigquery and bigquery
ml operations either on their own or
combined with other operations like
training automl and custom models
alongside bitcriminal to see which model
performs the best before deploying your
best model
so with crawl walk run from Dita to ml
and mlops uh what else might be new you
might be wondering
so how about tapping into the value of
unstructured data using machine learning
where your data is stored in your data
lake so this is where you can have data
stored in Google Cloud Storage like your
images and text files and make them
accessible in bigquery or big lake and
apply machine learning models directly
where the data is stored
so what does that look like now imagine
that you have a vacation rental company
and they want to predict the
click-through rate of rental homes on
their website
and their current uh prediction model
their current machine learning model
only looks at structure data so think of
that as the the size of the homes the
number of rooms in those homes uh the
location of those uh rental properties
and they have thousands of images at
homes not being used at all in part of
their model training as well so if they
want to apply machine learning to those
images of homes today that might be a
completely different flow for their data
scientists as opposed to where they're
doing their modeling of their structured
data
so with bigquery's new capabilities you
can actually use bigquery to index your
images your JPEG files or your PNG files
your uh that are stored on Google cloud
storage and so you can build this
connection between bigquery with cloud
storage via what we call Big Lake
so once you have that you can then
import a computer vision model like
imagenet which takes in images and
converts them into vectors that ml
models can use as inputs so in other
words we can use bigquery ml with the
computer vision models on those images
that are stored in cloud storage and
then get the prediction results as part
of a bigquery query like any other SQL
query that you might do so in other
words this unlocks Ai and ml
capabilities directly in bigquery where
before image data is unstructured and
therefore rather separate from the
structured data on these houses and now
they're combined together in bigquery
and this enables data scientists to
combine structured and unstructured data
to easily train even better machine
learning models
so with that I want to hand it over to
Irwin to give a quick demo of the
overall data to ml and Beyond flow Irwin
thank you very much Paul long and thank
you for the great presentation we now
know how we can go from data in bigquery
to having a model deployed on vertex AI
we know how we can start with crawling
walk and then run on Google Cloud let's
now see how that works in our demo let's
dive into the demo in this demo I will
show you how you can easily go from
crawl to walk and finally to run using
bigquery and vertex AI
as mentioned by prolonging the
presentation if you're a data scientist
business analyst or machine learning
engineering and you get started on the
vertex AI platform a good place to start
it's with vertex AI work
if we go to vertex AI we can navigate to
vertex AI workbench this is where we can
start our notebook environment from
where we can leverage all of the vertex
AI services and capabilities
so when we go to vertex AI workbench we
will see two different options we have
managed notebooks and we have user
managed notebooks user management books
lets you create
and manage a virtual machine instance
that has jupyter lab environment
pre-installed for you you can also
install your favor or choose your
favorite libraries
we have a notebook managed notebook
environment which is a fully managed
Jupiter based scalable notebook
environment
I'm using a managed notebook environment
today I already created one so let's go
to our managed notebook environment
let's go to Jupiter lab so as a data
scientist business analyst Machinery
engineer it is often challenging to
access or get access to data that we
need for our use cases
that's why we made it easy and we built
Integrations with Google cloud storage
and bigquery so that it's easy to
explore and access data that sits in
bigquery
if we go to the left we can here find
all of the bigquery data sets that we
have access to which could be the public
data sets or data sets within your
organization that you have access to
from here we can start exploring these
data sets so for example we can see the
details regarding this data set or the
schema of our data set in this case we
have Google analytics data that we're
using
and from here we can also query our
table
so we can write a SQL query submit it to
bigquery and get the results in our
notebook environment
we can even easily use this query and
submit it to bigquery and generate a
pandas data frame in our notebook that
we can then use to export this data into
train a machine learning model if we
want to train a custom model
let me copy this code and let me put
this in the cell and submit this query
to
bigquery and return the results in a
pandas data frame
so from here we can start them further
analyzing exploring preparing our data
for training a machine learning model so
when you want to train a machine
learning model using vertex AI or
bigquery or data set that sits in
bigquery there's different options for
you you can train a custom model you can
leverage automl or you can leverage
bigquery machine learning
so in this case we're going to train a
model using bigquery engineering so
through the SQL interface we're going to
train a logistic regression
and as mentioned now we have the option
to register your model on vertex AI
model registry so your bigquery ml model
will be registered on the model registry
we can add some aliases from here we can
submit this code to bigquery and we can
train our bigquery ml model of course
training a model takes a bit of time so
I already pre-trained the model for us
so if we go to vertex Ai and we navigate
to vertex AI model registry this is
where we found we'll find all of the
models that we registered on vertex AI
so here you also find our bigquery and
now model that we already trained so
from here it's very easy to deploy a
model into production so we say deploy
to endpoint
we specify an endpoint name
we can also specify and traffic split
the number of compute nodes the maximum
number of nodes for auto scaling the
machine type that we want to use for our
scaling and we can then deploy
I've already created an endpoint for us
so if we go into this endpoint we will
see that you also have the option to
deploy multiple models in this endpoint
to a traffic split set monitoring and
even set alerts to detect if something
is wrong with your model
now you'll probably ask so the process
until now our walking has been pretty
manual
we fetched data from bigquery we could
do some data exploration we train a
model we deploy this model but it's been
a manual process
so now it's time to add to start running
and add our ml Ops capabilities into
what we just created so we want to
automate and orchestrate the workflow
that we just gone through for this we
can leverage vertex AI Pipelines
I already pre-created a pipeline that
goes through the steps that we just
discussed it creates a bigquery model it
registers of course the model model
registry it evaluates the model
it creates an endpoint and it uploads
that endpoint uploads the model into
that endpoint
the advantage of having a pipeline is
that we can automate it orchestrate it
and keep track of lineage and artifacts
that are related to that pipeline so we
can for example keep track operation
metrics of the endpoint that we created
now you will probably ask how do I go
from the steps we showed earlier to
creating a pipeline like this
again this is
very easy to do so if we scroll all the
way down in our notebook I will show you
the code
to create this pipeline
for creating pipelines we can create
tensorflow extended Pipelines
or we can use kubeflow pipelines to
create our pipeline
in this case we are leveling kubeflow
pipelines and the pre-built
um components that we have for bigquery
ML that we talked about
so we have an a step a component that
create that trains and registers a model
that's one that evaluates our model the
one that creates our endpoint and then
the last step is uploading our model
into our input the advantage of build
using these pre-built components is that
we only need to specify the parameters
so for example what is our query so you
probably recognize this query this is
the creative we used earlier to train
and register our model
and then also of course you set the
location the project
and then the output of that component
goes into our model evaluation operation
we then create an endpoint and we then
deploy it so once we defined our
pipeline use using the kfp DSL
we generate a
we compile our pipeline into a Json file
and we then upload the Json file submit
it for a run to vertex AI Pipelines
so from here you can easily also clone
your pipeline and run it again with
maybe different configuration
so we've seen how we can go from chrome
get data from bigquery do some analysis
walk trainer first models and deploy our
model as an endpoint
and then run by adding ml Ops
capabilities through vertex AI pipelines
by automating and orchestrating this
pipeline
so that was your demo we're at the end
of our presentation so I want to thank
Poland again for the great presentation
and if you want to learn more about how
you can go from data to AI please have a
look at our data to AI workshop and we
hope to see you soon
[Music]